our next guest known for his quiet
demeanor at the University of Miami and
the Dallas Cowboys although he didn't
say much he let his play do the talking
in a supporting role - stars like Steve
Walsh and Bennie blades of the 1987
night will champion ship team in the NFL
he was commonly known as the third
triplet Troy Aikman once said he was his
second favorite target behind Jay
Novacek
please welcome
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you look like you're shaft that's a good
that's a compliment like that is a
compliment to be sure the original one
was Richard Roundtree
yes shaft right on and then you watch
can you dig it didn't send me well
played him in a movie I think yeah got
my part how many movies have you been ah
I think about three damaged so you said
you did more than me don't even know no
I did I did Mike I've been in 17 movies
17 yes Mike so you were in longest chart
we were both in Longest Yard and uh we
did what's the one Jack and Jill Jack
and Jill we're in that one we did Jack
and Jill and then there was this other
movie I did I don't well actually do two
more actually one to talk about but but
the other one was pretty good you don't
know what it is no I notice you were
stalling Michael listed in the Jerry
Maguire as well okay well I think they I
didn't really go in being in the movie I
just kind of used some highlights of
mine and they didn't send any chicks
okay that doesn't count
my wife says there's no money game and
she doesn't count that as work but
didn't the Cardinals play the Cowboys
with rod Tidwell was that the game that
they should yes the cowboy highlights
but then right exactly so they put us in
there but again I JIRA must have got
that money well how good do you think he
was as a wide receiver
ooh yeah what do you mean how good was
it
he looked like he had tell in selling
the piece yeah was good movie now I love
to move it I love the movie but you know
you could tell he was acting while
receiver wide receiver it's it takes
something to play the position you know
what I mean and it has to be engrafted
in your spirit because we're usually
with different people we talked about
the Antonio Brown and these guys out
here you got to understand we're the
most independent dependent person in the
world we're out lied by ourselves well
we can't do anything without someone
else independent dependent which brings
conflict within your spirit so people
call us beavers and all of that but
really we're just complex people I mean
you guys lean D on no you have that on
is of course you do he will expect me
you know III just like her love Sam
Smith that's kind of music I listen to I
think because I'm so big and black and
hard they think I listen to all the hard
stuff but you don't listen to rap I do
my son my son rapped his name is Tut
Tarantino wait what
my son right what's his name he he raps
on the terror t know his real name is he
lied to Irving okay but listen I'll get
his I swear if you go on I told to
listen to him he raps about some of the
horrors in the world and I said sure
[Applause]
where does this stuff come from
your son is using your childhood you
can't rap about a private education
that's what and the guy just tells me am
I coulda saw young guys young kids
expressed themselves you just gotta let
him go through this and everything I'm
like well what does any reflection on my
parenting what's mine think about this
well long time he wouldn't let mom hear
his music you know yeah I couldn't hear
for awhile and then I finally heard he
because he started getting out on iTunes
he had a cup albums out there nice like
like man I mean you said every Sunday in
church funny stuff man when you hear I
like rap I like when did you decide
because I do feel there's an entertainer
in every athlete to a certain degree
you'd like to perform you'd like to
perform in front of people but there had
to be a moment I don't know what you
were like in high school but when you
got to the you there was an entertainer
that was in there and I don't know if
you knew it was there well I got a lot
of people now cuz I grew up you know
we're like sit with a big family and
around people and everything so so yeah
and I love laughter he's like you guys
that's the greatest thing in the world I
don't care what crosses everything we
can have fun we laugh we could joke and
and since I made a lot of dumb decisions
and stuff like that I like to laugh at
me too and people laugh with you if you
will laugh at you so I I do enjoy that
aspect
of it and and and just giving truth out
and in the most funny thing I think it's
always in everyday thing the Bible says
and those things that are common they're
all men we all have those things and you
can stand in I think find funny things
all day yeah but you're catching the
first down and granted you would get a
four yard pass right and you made it
seem like you got an 80-yard what
because this is right it can take the
journey from goal line-- the goal line--
is a long journey in between it in order
to get that through that long journey I
thought one of the young either said if
I just had a few small celebrations
along the way but if I just make a small
celebration here small celebration here
small celebration did not get to the big
celebration
so the first days we came the small
celebration and if you just keep getting
the small celebration you'll end up
getting the big one that's why I always
sit so I started doing the celebrations
on the first celebration celebrating oh
my god what do you mean besides me yeah
dealings ID always good
yeah always good and we used to come up
with stuff I mean we wait would you
practice it oh yeah it's so much fun man
I'm thinking about this what do you
think about thinking about this hey I'm
thinking about doing this just just you
know cuz we had a good rate eeeem and so
we have fun with it we took it to the
next level we already knew we were gonna
win the game but did you let's come up
with some stuff in the Superbowl okay we
know we're going to win let's drive the
price for the MVP up nobody signs the
deal with Disney World nobody signs a
deal David maybe they pay people
twenty-five fifty thousand dollars
nobody settles for less than 150 so if
nobody signs right Detroit agreed to so
I wouldn't participate
these guys don't come here with that
stuff actually Emmett didn't Roy win one
yes that was the first one okay man when
we got to that about the third when we
figured that we should second it though
we should kind of collude on this deal
so we try to drive up the price
that was the finals fun days man of fun
days I try to tell these young guys now
enjoy this moment you know we get to
reminisce on our history you're writing
your history make sure you write will so
you can reminisce well later on because
I promise you you're going to want to
did the Cowboys have a successful season
you got in the playoffs you won the
division I have to say that's a
successful season it didn't they didn't
get to where they want it to be and I
think if they didn't wait so long to
make the decision or if they didn't
think that they can go in with a bunch
of number twos and threes at wide
receivers before I urge them to go get
Amari Cooper that raised the level up
you know what I mean they they claim did
you tell Jerry to go get Amari Cooper
hey man listen you don't you don't think
he listens to me
I'm just asking I'm listening to you I
want to know if he's listening
when Jerry bought that team it was a
hundred and fifty million dollars after
I gave him those three Super Bowls
knives were billion dollar Wow you
should listen so you gave him them when
I what I did oh yes I did
what do you mean if I was there you
think he would've gotten those three
Super Bowls if I was not there
absolutely I gave people plenty people
rings that a lot of guys didn't even
play on them to wait I was with seal and
Boomer Esiason I said minnow you guys
going to the game and they were like
well we don't have tickets the game was
in that's it you need tickets let's say
what you mean et I said man and games in
Dallas I'm pulling up in my belly won't
open the gate
Jerry's bop ain't nobody saying a word
[Laughter]
was Cole Beasley correct in what he was
saying that the front office is the one
who decides who gets the football thrown
to them it's impossible it's flat-out
impossible that the front office can
make a decision well okay but they could
because Jerry could say to Jason I wanna
I want to make sure Mary Cooper gets the
ball I want to prove that we got a great
deal when we traded a first-round pick
for Amari Cooper I don't think that's
far-fetched to say that Mike okay is
Cole Beasley good enough to be a Julian
Edelman tonight you hit the nail on the
head
Colby's and wants to be Julian Edelman
but he's not in Julian elderman like
office Tom Brady plays the game
inside-out so he's going to play with
Gronk
Julian Edelman and the guys on the
outside we'll get to you later
the Cowboys play the game outside in
depth one to the wide receivers outside
and if they get double-team now your
one-on-one inside will throw the ball
inside Pisa has to understand that that
doesn't come from Jerry from Jerry Jones
upstairs see that's that's that's the
the philosophy of the office okay I got
a couple of questions for you I don't
know if you'll think they're good
legitimate questions would you rather
have Julian Edelman career or Calvin
Johnson
Julian element or Calvin Johnson I I'm
in the Superbowl rings buddy okay all
right I said Julian Edelman - yes I'm in
Super Bowl rings you know ultimate and I
would take your career over Calvin
Johnson of course yeah you know I just
wanted to let you
there's reason I met a guy the other day
nice it man like man you know you each
talking about random monster most bad
boy I say he said yeah I said but you
know ran most didn't win a ring he said
uh he said yeah so so you want a ring to
me I said no no no no no I'm a s brother
he said what do you mean you're s
brother I won as in plural are you
better than me
are you are you better than Randy Moss
I'm a yes brother
let this tell you that I got rings or
levels but then that means that Julian
Edelman is better than Randy Moss
because he has rings yeah that's what I
say that's what I say game of football
is the game of football but there's a
purpose to it all of my catches in rings
better career Gronk or Jason Witten Rock
rings but they're both first-ballot Hall
of Famers okay they'll be first-ballot
Hall of Fame what happens on Sunday
that's going to be a good game now
because now this team here
the Rams have everything they need to to
beat the Patriots and I let me tell you
what I love about this too I love the
stories of football right look at this
here you got the golden coach the goat
coach in a go quarterback going up
against the young guys young guys
argument you've had with mom and dad
when dad I was what shut up you don't
know nothing now a young guy said oh we
know something now we're in this Super
Bowl so this is this is a great game
it's a great opportunity for for Sean
McVeigh and Jared golf to strike it for
the young people that didn't know
anything and I beat their old head but
it's going to be tough they got all look
they got all the tools they need but
just executing them sometimes it's a
different thing goes Tom Brady and
Belichick they just execute they
just execute may be boring may not be
nice may not be fancy nothing that works
for you Instagram and your Twitter but
they just win football games be easy
that straight way they just oh it's just
so hard to be alright I want I want the
Rams to win but it's hard to go against
those Patriots man
his heart is Brady better than Troy the
Brady's the greatest of all time all
right Bar None I know you're territorial
with Troy
but now Brady's the greatest of all time
but I'm ok I will still take Troy over
everybody period I would take Troy over
everybody so if we had a draft right now
and you can have Brady or tear Oy or
anyone else oh I'll take to you Roy okay
Brady's great for his system Brady can't
play in but I don't think Brady can play
like in Troy's system I think Troy
you're playing Brady system cuz Troy has
an arm to throw outside strong arm
though bang aides DPS deep outs he has a
great arm for that and he could still
throw the inside things Brady and his
sister if you give me you say take any
quarterback now in the league and and we
don't know what office were putting them
in I'm still I will take air Rodgers I
take care of Rodgers over Tom Brady I'll
take a few people over Tom Brady but if
you say take them and we're going to put
them in their system and I'm taking Tom
Brady one onedrive game on the line you
can have Troy or you can have Tom and in
what office they're in their office yes
I've wanted them I'm winning with either
one I'm winning with Troy I'm winning
I've been in that onedrive game on the
line let's go get these rings we want to
got those rings and I've watched Tom
Brady onedrive Game one in live we just
watch that pass in the championship game
and he went and got him you know it's
it's incredible man we are so blessed to
say we live in this time you know that
we lived and it's III think about the
people that watch the Lombardi who
actually got a chance to watch on body
and watch them coach and you know
I hope they could appreciate it like I
hope we get a chance to appreciate a
Belichick and what he's done
sinister Dan it is incredible I know in
this theater when they give it all them
brothers all that money guaranteed now
is you know jimmy johnson controls with
fear but like you know you got thirty
four to fifty million dollars guarantee
they can't cut you now you got to find
other ways to manage and mitigate
through issues and he's been doing he's
just rated during the live look and we
want to try to imitate your first down
celebration okay oh yeah and you'll be
the judge okay yeah you can see him on
the NFL Network Super Bowl Sunday
hold on Mike you can see Mike on Super
Bowl so hold on Mike okay come on Super
Bowl Sunday it's a special eight and a
half hour edition it's only gonna feel
like eight not eight and a half NFL
gameday morning starting at 9:00 a.m.
Eastern on the NFL Network thank you go
write it up banging that means you're
going you can get banged up by the
segment that means you're running it and
you want to just a slight turn right
here you don't want me to come by right
here and I play to say no no no I don't
want you
[Laughter]
okay okay all right all right so I have
to take a Liberty okay all right take
your Liberty but that's it I'll be out
here all day baby
anthro come in so you get title
you gotta come up the crowd is there
don't just go for more Dan Patrick show
to the audience Channel 239 on Direct TV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]